[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm genau wie ein
problem für mittelalter haben könnte man
sich fragen was die zeitgrenzen der erde
der renaissance sein würde würden
und da habe ich keine so feste meinung
aber nur die beobachtung dass es eine
zeit gibt es wo die geschichte der
philosophie zwar stattgefunden hat aber
wenig beachtet wird und das ist mehr
oder weniger mein natürlich das mehr
oder weniger die zeit zwischen hat ließ
und der karte aber ist innerhalb dieser
großen lücke die oft in der geschichte
der flüsse wie auftaucht gibt es eine
eine besondere lücke zwischen hochs
klassik und moderne
das ist das heißt eigentlich die zeit
zwischen dem späten 40ern und
jahrhundert und etwa 1600 17 jahrhundert
ist natürlich sehr berühmter weise sehr
wichtig in der geschichte wieder an der
deka und uns leid netz davor haben wir
die hawks cola sticker thomas von aquin
des marktes haben wir schon besprochen
letzte woche seines coaches wir haben
von art com und so weiter so bekannten
namen werden in rasanz für das wie wenig
818 in der zum beispiel für vorlesungen
bekommt hier ist münchen etwas eine
ausnahme weil wir sogar einen lehrstuhl
für philosophie der songs haben der
leider im moment nicht besetzt ist aber
trotzdem haben wir das aber weltweit
sozusagen ist flossen wie in der
renaissance sehr wenig erforscht und
wenig kommt wenn ich im unterricht vor
und
wie passt es deswegen zu dieser
vorlesungsreihe wo wir mehrere
philosophische koalition besprochen
haben die auch wenig aufmerksamkeit
bekommen auf jeden fall ich werde jetzt
in der heutigen sitzung eigentlich mich
eigentlich auf flüsse wie in italien in
vom senden und sachsen jahrhundert
konzentrieren nicht weil es nur für
leute wie in jener zeit in italien
gegeben hat sondern weil ich mehr
darüber gelesen habe und weil es besser
an die themen anschließt die wir schon
besprochen haben
unter anderem weil quellen die wir schon
betrachtet haben als wir antike und
spätantike diskutiert haben jetzt wieder
dann in die diskussion reinkommen und
das gilt vor allem für ios und der
abstinenzler
sie erinnert sich daran dass haben wir
vielleicht im november bis wochen oder
so das war der spätantike text dieses
neue platine christoph julius wo er
argumentieren wollte das tier dass
fleischkonsum gegen das philosophische
leben ist und dass die opfer und
fleischkonsum schlecht es dagegen
argumentiert hat sie vielleicht erinnern
sie sich auch daran dass er dafür
plädiert hat das tierisch packen können
und dass die historiker deswegen unrecht
hatten als sie bei havel haben das wäre
unvernünftig sind also den von texten im
sinne von mangelnder vernunft dass sie
nicht denken können und als sie das und
um das behaupten haben sie dann darauf
hingedeutet dass tiere mit sprechen
können
und dagegen hat vorausgesagt doch wir
können doch sprechen und diese ideen
kommen jetzt noch mal in die
philosophische debatte hinein weil sie
den text wieder haben was sie im
mittelalter nicht hatten und auch in der
arabisch
bald hatten oder in der islamischen welt
hatten genau in dieser zeit also im 15
16 jahrhundert gibt es auch natürlich
eine große und philosophisch sehr
bedeutsame entwicklung in nordeuropa
nämlich natürlich die reformation und
ich vermute dass man wahrscheinlich
tiere und reformation philosophen und
theologen auch sehr tief diskutieren
könnte vielleicht hätte ich noch eine
ganze vorlesung dazu halten können
das werde ich aber nicht machen würde
mich auf die entwicklungen in italien
konzentrieren war das wie sie sehen
werden genügt das reichlich weil die
situation satz nur haien und auch ohne
dass wir reformation und
gegenreformation display schwachen war
die situation in italien relativ
kompliziert ich würde sogar sagen dass
wir drei strömungen hier haben oder
vielleicht eine strömung mit zwei
aspekten und dann eine andere stimmen
nämlich des klassizismus humanismus und
atheismus wobei platin ismus eine
wirkung des humanismus war also wenn wir
zb an latte platonischer wie marcelo für
kino- oder pico de marie claire anderer
denken dann haben wir mit humanisten zu
tun die gleichzeitig plattform agrar
cent ich werde kurz erklären was ich
unter kommunismus verstehe aber
grundsätzlich gibt es und das ist
wahrscheinlich in allen bekannt es gibt
eine eine gegenüberstellung in dieser
zeit jederzeit zwischen des rassismus
und kommunismus
das gilt übrigens auch für nordeuropa zb
nordeuropa haben wir leute wie zum
beispiel erasmus ein sehr bekannter
berühmter komponist und wir haben auch
die andauernden us tradition in den
universitäten in frankreich deutschland
oder deutschland also im deutschen
bereich und in england und so weiter das
ist rassismus ist bis ende des 14
jahrhundert ca ein europäisches phänomen
streckt sich von trat im osten nach
oxford im westen und ist auch in italien
präsent und wir können das mit der neuen
humanistischen bewegung dann
kontaktieren
das ist das was sehr grundlegend für die
ganze renaissance ich denke dass man oft
also wenn man eine renaissance flosse
wie denkt denkt man am häufigsten an
kommunismus und vielleicht platin ismus
als ein teil oder ein aspekt der
kommunistischen bewegung und das ist
nicht falsch lässt aber rassismus außer
acht
also man könnte fast sagen erstens wird
wenig gesprochen und zweitens wenn sie
gesprochen wird wird es klassische
philosophie in der instanz noch weniger
besprochen
ich wollte aber zeigen dass die dass
unsere themen also diese themen über
über psychologie und moralische fragen
sortiere doch auf beiden seiten
auftauchen und dass das geld für die
ganze bandbreite der denkern dieser zeit
es gibt humanisten die eigentlich keine
plateau nicholsons es gibt humanisten
die platonischer sind und es gibt es
klassiker die verschiedene meinungen zu
äußern
und es handelt sich nicht unbedingt von
einer breiten kritik
gegen zb aristotelische auffassung der
kjm philosophie das hören stattdessen
haben ist sind modifikationen zu der
sensation tiere innerhalb des atheismus
und dann auch kritik gegen sozialismus
von kommunisten mit einem beispiel davon
anzufangen dachte ich dass ich zuerst
leute an so walla erwähnen würde der
esta 1457 gestorben
und ist das paradebeispiel eines mannes
der stalinismus kritisiert er hat eine
ein langes werk dialektiker geschrieben
in dem er eine ganze reihe von
kritikpunkten gegen aldershot ließ
bietet bzw gegen die solistische fassung
der station philosophie aber erkennt die
werke hat das selbst relativ gut ließ
sie aber sozusagen durch die linse der
stets gallas muss nun was er hier
wirklich machen will ist also zeigen
dass philosophie einen neuanfang haben
könnte wo man als basis nichts die werke
des ortes vernimmt sondern was anderes
nämlich die hauptwerke der
humanistischen tradition
das heißt für ihn antiken rhetorik und
vor allem cicero nicht allein es gibt
mehrere kommunisten am anfang vor allem
am anfang des 15 15
am anfang des jahres 15 jahrhunderts die
diese auf dieser auffassung sind dass
sie wollen philosophie weitermachen aber
als solist mit cicero ersetzen mehr oder
weniger aber war da ist es einfach ein
radikaler als einmal als die meisten in
der hinsicht dass er alles orte ließ und
es gar das ist
es ist klasse dass müssen wirklich sehr
sehr scharf kritisiert sarkastisch
lustig sie wirklich ein sehr
unterhaltsames berg also unter werke
über das hotel ische dialektik ist das
vielleicht des unterhalts handelte was
es gibt
das vielleicht nicht viel sagt aber
trotzdem und es gibt eine lange passage
in an diesem berg wo er die frage angeht
ob es wirklich wichtig ist
tiere und menschen zu und dadurch zu
unterscheiden das tier dialoge sind also
das heißt unvernünftig oder nicht
vernünftig wenn es menschen vernünftig
sind und da sagt er nein beziehungsweise
weil er die ganze aristotelische
psychologie angreifen sie erinnern sich
das hab ich das muss ich immer wieder
auf schreiben wir haben ein paar
pflanzen tier seele vernunft seele und
der mensch hat alle drei fällen
beziehungsweise haben wir eine serie die
all diese fähigkeiten kombiniert
irgendwie wir kommen noch mal dazu zu
dieser frage zurück dies zu dieser
einheits frage
und das heißt dass wir denken können
wahrnehmen und umsatz bewegen können und
sich und uns ernähren können
fortpflanzen und das erste was er hier
sagt interessanterweise ist das pflanzen
keine serien besitzen weil weil und das
ist sehr typisch für waller er bringt
eine theologische begründung dafür
nämlich die verbindung zwischen anima
zelle und anni mal also dem tier ja also
das tier ist das was die eine seele hat
und eine theologisch
und pflanzen haben sind keine tiere
haben keine anima und deswegen haben sie
keine ahnung weil sie an ihm hätten dann
wären sie animalis das einzige was was
eine pflanze machen kann ist ist zum
beispiel so wachsen
aber wenn wir sagen würden dass alles
was wächst eine zelle hat dann würde man
sagen müssen dass unsere haare wenn wir
hätten dass unsere haare auch eine
beseelt ist ja lächerlich und das ist
übrigens typisch für walter er
verspottet die ausstellung dadurch dass
er immer diese witzige dann ein wende
bringt also einerseits will er die
pflanzen ausschließen aus dem bereich
der seltenen wesen andererseits also er
will die die pflanzen so sagen niedriger
einstufen als tiere als die vorher
eingestuft worden sind im gegensatz dazu
will er die tiere höher einstufen und
hier sagt er dass die ganzen diese ganze
idee dass tiere keine keine vernunft
besitzen ist noch mal nicht noch mal an
ethnologie aber in diesem fall an einer
falschen etymologie weil das wort hallo
gab
hier will er natürlich zeigen dass er
griechisch kann und dass ein altes ganz
klasse ist und dass er das wirklich ich
kann als disco lastiger was heißt also
das heißt gute frage
das ist das sind wesen die keinen logos
besitzen
aber was ist los das haben wir schon
gehabt und das besteht weiter auch das
heißt einerseits sprache andererseits
vernunft und dann sagt er
die disco laster und autos office
schließen aus der aus der tatsache dass
jede keine sprache besitzen dass sie
keine wohnung besitzen weil es nur ein
wort ist das ist aber falsch
wie wir sehen können dadurch dass wir
beobachten das tier offensichtlich
denken können und hier bringt er
beispiel wie die und der art die uns
schon bekannt ist es zb ein tier der den
weg aus werden will diesen mal dieses
mal ist ein fertig ein hund ähnlich mit
dem mit christus als beispiel
wir haben ein tier muss sich entscheiden
welchen weg nimmt es nehmen soll
und da überlegt das tier und nimmt den
weg was richtig ist und das zeigt dass
tiere vernunft haben wenn nicht so viel
vernunft menschen nur nicht nur keine
sprache und das unterminiert nicht nur
die apostolische entschuldigen
die apostolische tier für das wie
sondern auch sogar die klassische
definition die immer wieder ins glas ist
müsste es auftaucht des menschen der
mensch wie wir mehrmals erwähnt haben
der menschen wird als vernünftiges tier
definiert und jetzt sagt er nein war
dass es das ist eine allgemeine
definition das betrifft auch zum
beispiel pferde und nicht nur menschen
das ist keine gute definition deswegen
scheitert diese klassische lehre alles
sehr typisch für wale und natürlich
nicht nicht eine diskussion die er
unternommen hat um unbedingt irgendwas
über tiere so zu sagen oder zu sagen er
will nur peinliches über die erste
celica sagen und nimmt also der reihe
nach typische als ätherische lehre und
widerlegt
die lehre einen punkt nach dem anderen
und zwischendurch kommt diese tiere
frage vor
deswegen kann man nicht einmal unbedingt
das legen wie ernster das wirklich meins
das ganze werk ist ja dialektisch wieder
täglich was gesagt und ob es wirklich so
wichtig ist dass tiere denken kann es
nicht klar er will nur gute argumente
gegen die adidas-titel verbünden
das ist aber ein gutes beispiel von
diesem phänomen was in der sonst flüsse
wie vor als sehr auffällig ist nämlich
dass humanisten diese klassische kennen
und ihr wissen über klassische sprachen
vor allem einsetzen um distanz von arosa
tourismus zu nehmen und um zu zeigen
dass die immer noch existierende
situation des klassizismus was an den
universitäten noch herrscht irgendwie
nicht ausreichend ist
übrigens habe ich etwa ergänzen es gibt
eine stelle bei kilian ein antiker
patrick autor also ein artikel otto
reeker und eliane auch sagt dass tiere
irgendwie an vernunft teilhaben
das ist auch eine inspiration für das
argument was war hier bringt das ist
noch mal typisch für minister
wenn er zwischen aristoteles und können
die zilien entscheiden muss dann geht ja
immer mit könnten niemals alles okay
also dass nur ein beispiel aber auch
wenn vale sgs es lieber sehen würde dass
ich dieses plastik gar nicht besprechen
würde werde ich das jetzt tun und ich
werde vor allem die sogenannte
partnerschule glaube dass partner heißt
auch partner auf deutsch oder ob das
wirklich eine schule ist ist umstritten
und das müssen wir uns nicht entscheiden
alles was sie wissen müssen ist das
genau wie
florenz 1 zentrum für platonische flosse
wie im callcenter in sachsen jahrhundert
waren vor zehn jahren den euro pico und
polizei waren alle in grenze also in
florenz genauso also pazifismus in
florenz alles sozialismus in partout
nicht nur ein partner natürlich und
platin ist muss nicht nur auch nicht nur
im verein aber das ist sehr prägend für
diese zwei städte in padua haben wir der
höhepunkt der italienischen renaissance
des tourismus des klassizismus wegen
denkern wie paparazzi und agostini vor
die ich jetzt beide diskutieren möchte
und hier haben wir nicht nur mit der
journalismus zu tun
wir haben auch sogar mit terrorismus zu
tun
farrow ist gestorben halt 98 war habe
ich erwerbe es überhaupt erwähnt dass er
irgendwann schon oder würde nichts
wahrscheinlich sehr ausführlich
diskutiert es war ein kommentator über
hdj ließ der im zwölften jahrhundert in
analysieren gelebt hat glaube ich habe
ihn damals erwähnt um es zu sagen dass
er eindeutig dass er etwas grenzwertig
war in der geschichte der islamischen
fluss vivaldi in den kerngebieten der
islamischen welt designer viel wirksamer
war und dieses projekt zu wo er alles
kommentiert hat war deswegen in der
islamischen welt nicht sehr
einflussreich in der lateinischen welt
oder den der welt das rad des
klassizismus war sehr sehr einflussreich
und da kann man sogar sagen dass es ab
dem hat der mitte des 20 jahrhunderts
das frühe moderne also durch fünfzehnte
und sechs center jahrhunderts ist alois
der haupt die hauptquelle für al assad
ließ exegese und wird sogar
ein ein denker der so interessant ist
wie er es selbst oder fast so
interessant also die diesen vor allem im
parador diese leute haben immer alles
nebenerwerbs gelesen und haben sogar
kommentare zu die kommentare von erwerbs
geschrieben also so genannte super
kommentare das finden wir auch übrigens
in der jüdischen tradition es gab ein
philosoph namens der sony dies der auch
larry ben carson aber sein spitzname ist
der sonne dies wird auch kommentare zu
oasis kommentare geschrieben sie können
sich vorstellen wie lange die sind wobei
die kommentare die kommentar kommentare
die er kommentiert haben hat waren nicht
die längste kommentaren von avery
sondern die sogenannte mittlere
kommentaren also paraphrasen das
inzwischen textes auf jeden fall was
wirklich auffällig hier ist ist das
alles sehr ernst genommen als
paradebeispiel eines technischen fehlers
offs ist irgendwie klar deutlich
leichter zu überstehen als er das hat
mich selbst ist der wegweiser für
aristotelische floss wie durch diese
ganzes klassische zeit und das war
problematisch insofern das aws noch
klarer als alles ort ließ weder die
linie gelehrt hat die höchst umstritten
waren bzw
sogar unannehmbar unter den unternehmen
zwei haupt beide spiele zu erwähnen sind
erstens hat er die ewigkeit des
universums akzeptiert das wollen es
nicht so relevant wobei man nicht
vergessen soll dass das doch mit tieren
auch zu tun hat wenn wir sagen dass das
die welt oder das universum ewig sei das
bringt mit sich die die annahme oder die
behauptung dass die welt so wie sie
jetzt ist immer schon so existiert hat
mit einer spezies die wir jetzt finden
also das heißt denn wenn er behauptet
eines ortes oder service behauptet dass
das universum ewig sei das heißt auch
dass zum beispiel als immer gelaufen
gegeben hat und kühle und frische und
war kassel und so weiter es geht bis ins
unendliche zurück und auch
wahrscheinlich in unendliche in den zug
in die zukunft es hat schon immer
kaninchen gegeben und das ist wichtig
weil die wir gesehen haben weil wir
damit sichern können dass die aussagen
der station wissenschaft auch ewig
gültig sind zb wenn wir sagen kaninchen
sind pflanzenfresser pflanzenfresser das
gilt für ewig nicht nur seitdem es
kaninchen gibt für die letzte paar
zehntausend jahre oder weiß ich wie lang
in münchen schon existiert haben aber
wir würden sagen nicht nicht zeit immer
aber die richter sagen seid immer und
das ist wichtig weil diese wahrheit dann
bleibt für immer bestehen und das war
übrigens ein hauptgrund warum euro ist
diese lehre aufrecht halten wollte er
wollte ein ewiges universum damit die
tiere halten auch ewig sind und das war
sehr umstritten zweite these die
umstritten war die these der einheit des
internationen das ist was ich eigentlich
besprechen wollte
wir haben mehrmals gesehen wie wichtig
es war in der station tradition dass der
menschliche intellekts keine einzelne
dinge begreift sondern universalen also
im universelle begriffe oder objekte
formen wie wir ja wenn man das
ausdrücken will
das heißt wenn ich meinen intellekt
wirklich einsätze das heißt immer dass
ich zb im allgemeinen begreife das
kaninchen pflanzenfresser sind wurde das
graphen einen langen hals haben nicht
dass diese grafe einen langen hals hat
dass es gibt keine grafik nicht so viel
aber es stellen sie sich vor es gibt
einen geraten
eine giraffe draußen im hof dann würde
ich würde die wir mehrmals gesagt haben
würde ich empfinden dass diese gerade
einen langen hals hat aber nichts mit
meinem internet
das würde ich mit meiner mit meiner
wahrnehmung machen können oder wie wir
jetzt das machen wir wurden das
vorstellen
wir stellen uns vor dass es eine graf im
hof gibt mit einem langen hals
wenn wir aber begreifen dass und
vielleicht warum grafen einen langen
hals haben müssen dann schweben wir auf
einer anderen ebene dass es die ebene
dass das der wissenschaft das internet
und wer ist hat das sehr ernst genommen
und hat zwischen zwei bereichen
vielleicht unterschieden
wir haben einzelne dinge die aus materie
bestehen
es sind körper
und wir haben deswegen zum beispiel auch
der menschliche körper und alle seine
fähigkeiten wahrnehmung vorstellung
verdauen bewegung und so weiter und dann
gibt es intellekt der die universalen
begreift und jetzt stellt er die frage
wie sollen wir diesen intellekt und
theologisch verstehen und macht mehrere
versuche das zu machen er hat aber
sollten dieses thema über die seile drei
mal kommentiert 3 x 3 länge also kurze
kommentar mit der kommentar lange
kommentar und dem langen kommentar kommt
er zu dem schluss dass es nur eine
gruppe oder es gibt nur die eine
universalen die es gibt zum beispiel es
gibt nur ein' ein universelles eine
universelle giraffe es gibt nichts es
gibt mehrere giraffen aber die
universelle graf ist nur eins und der
intellekt ist nur dasjenige was diese
universal ihn begreift deswegen kann es
nur einen internet geben
anders argumentiert das was zum beispiel
graf von grafit unterscheidet ist dass
grafik a und b aus verschiedenen
materien gemacht werden oder haus mit
verschiedenen materie bestehen hier oben
gibt es keine materie in den intellekt
also ist das ist der intellekt nur eins
wir können zwar intellekt nicht
unterscheiden was sie keine materie
besitzen
es gibt keine liebe heutzutage seien
würden es gibt keine kein prinzip der
individuation für
zwei hinterlegte weil sie beide genau
das gleiche begreifen würden und keine
materie besitzen also gleiche aktivität
oder handlung und keine materie wodurch
wir sie unterscheiden können das müssten
sie identisch und aus diesen und
ähnlichen gründen kommt er zu dem
schluss dass es nur einen internet gibt
für die ganze menschheit und das ist
hier wichtig übrigens zu betonen es war
es kam mir schon mehrmals in der
geschichte was wie vor allem neue
platten ismus vor dass es einen
universellen internet gibt also ein
internet der zum beispiel mit der ideen
der platonischen ideen identisch ist
aber was neu ist hierbei ist dass er
konstatieren will dass dieser
universeller intellekt diese
einheitliche intellekt nur eins ist für
die ganze menschheit
das heißt wenn es sie wirklich denken
sie benutzten genau denselben intellekt
den ich benutze wenn ich denke wir
teilen diesen internet beziehungsweise
er würde es vielleicht anders sehen und
sagen dass dieser intellekt unsere der
körper benutzt um es zu denken weil als
gute erste liga weist er da sein
intellekt nur denken dass der
menschliche internet mindestens nur
denken kann wenn er mit wahrnehmung eine
vorstellung und gedächtnis gefüttert
wird
zum beispiel kann der menschliche
intellekt verstehen was ein kaninchen
oder einer giraffe ist nur dadurch dass
er dass ein mensch mit wahrnehmung
gedächtnis vorstellung mit graphen und
kaninchen erfahrungen gemacht hat diese
erfahrungen finden hier statt
aber das denken findet hier statt auf
universelle ebene und nur einmal per
minute also seine behauptung werde es
gibt immer genügend philosophen auf der
erde
damit alle ideen im internet vorhanden
sind
die meisten menschen machen gar nichts
dafür
weil sie nicht intellektuell denken weil
sie keine wissenschaft zweiten aber die
wissenschaftler halten diesen intellekts
praktisch sie halten das bleibt
weiterhin existieren dadurch dass sich
diese erfahrungen machen damit der
intellekt weiter denken kann und jetzt
denken sie wahrscheinlich das klingt
ziemlich verrückt und das denkt was
jeder der das hört und das dachten auch
die die meisten mit alten philosophen
zwar sehr sehr umstritten unter anderem
weil die die partie übliche art und
weise die menschliche unsterblichkeit zu
begründen war sie sagen dass menschen
eine intellektuelle fähigkeit haben die
sie pop ohne korb körper einsetzen
können und das zeigt dass die zelle nach
dem körperlichen tod weiterhin
existieren kann weil jeder von uns um
körperlich denken kann
das heißt dass wir es gibt irgendetwas
was wir noch immer noch machen können
nachdem wir sterben nämlich weiter
denken
aber jetzt kommt der paris und sagt nein
es gibt dessen nur praktisch eine
gemeinsame aktivität woran viele
menschen teilhaben aber das hat nichts
mit mir zu tun im besonderen das ist
genau die selbe aktivität die sie machen
werden sie wenn sie denken oder die
alles schon gemacht hat als er gedacht
hat also hat es dort ließ ist jetzt weg
jetzt haben wir nur dieses diesen
intellekt und deswegen gibt es
zahlreiche versuche die these und die
lehre zu widerlegen berühmtes beispiel
wie thomas von aquin im späten zweiten
jahrhundert schreibt ein werk gegen
gegen die terroristen weil er nach
seiner meinung nach gab es philosophen
in der damaligen
universität paris die diese lehre
akzeptieren wollten
und er wollte diese leute unter
werberings gleichzeitig widerlegen und
auch zeigen dass das eine falsche
auslegung von als dort lesbar
das wollte ihm sehr wichtig zu zeigen
dass das dort ließ im kran war weil er
eben das nicht sagte aber das ist nicht
so leicht war es natürlich sehr
gründlich gezeigt hat wie man diese
lehre aus dem text green das von sonys
gewinnen könnte jetzt werden wir weiter
gucken vorwärtsgehen summe 15
jahrhundert haben wir diese philosophie
oder sogar zum sex anja und dem 16
jahrhundert kommen wir zu dieser schule
oder gruppe von adele kann die an der
universität padua präsent war und für
sie war da war das jetzt ein brennendes
problem was sie aus dieser lehre machen
wollten
und vielleicht vielleicht haben sie
übrigens auch die sorge dass es hier
scheint dass ich seit zehn minuten nicht
über tiere gesagt habe aber wenn sie nur
kurz nachdenken sehen sie was das mit
tieren zu tun hat nach dieser lehre gibt
es hier um sozusagen diesen menschlichen
intellekt und das ist das eigentlich
menschliche und das ist ein tier sein
wenn wir das ernst nehmen das was wahrer
kritisiert hat dass das was den menschen
ist und nur das was man menschen ein
eigenes ist denken intellektuelles
denken dann scheint es dass wir nur eine
sanitäre sind die nur menschen sind weil
wir teil an diesem universum intellekt
haben und das ist natürlich eine
überraschende lehre und vor dem tische
leute aus den gründen die ich schon
erwähnt habe
und die müssen dann so damit
zurechtkommen würden auch heftig
kritisiert von anderen das beispiel von
den humanisten weil sie diese lehre
ernst genommen haben zum beispiel
kino ein sehr starker gegner dieser
these jetzt kommen wir so pietro papa
nazi gestorben 1525 der ein werk
tractatus die mortalität geschrieben hat
das heißt sagt hat zur unsterblichkeit
und in diesem text argumentiert er hat
sogar mehrere texte so psychologie also
zwischen psychologie schwimmen und
diesem text voltaire mit dieser werde
zurückkommen und das ausschließen weil
sie sich er wollte diesen einheitlichen
juristischen intellekt weg aus der
aristotelischen lehre bekommen und um
das zu tun reagierte so stark gegeben
dass er die unsterblichkeit der
menschheit der drittel der menschen
völlig infrage gesetzt hat denn er
um das zu vermeiden sagt er ja der
mensch ist ein behälter körper der immer
im besten fall gleichzeitig universal
ian und einzelne dinge begreift zb
nehmen wir an wir haben einen einen
grafen wissenschaftler und er will seine
wissenschaft der giraffen einsetzen
zuerst gewinnen dann einsetzen die macht
ihr das rang bekannte geschichte
erfahrungen mit gerafften hervor strafen
die graphen sind immer einzelne gelaufen
sind wahrnehmbar ist antastbar sogar und
daraus gewinnt er eindrücke und
gedächtnis über giraffen und kommt dann
letztendlich zu universen aussagen über
giraffen die er über aber immer nur eins
wenn es um weiterhin um einzelne grafen
zb diese getafe in der m hof er kann
sagen diese grafe hat einen langen hals
weil alle grafen einen langen hals haben
weil sie blatter
platter erreichen müssen wir erreichen
müssen
aber es gibt keinen denken was wirklich
getrennt von der welt der einzelne dinge
geschieht mindestens nicht beim menschen
vielleicht bei gott oder bei den engeln
aber bei uns nicht deswegen braucht man
diesen sozusagen reinen inter
lackierungen gar nicht das machen wir
nicht was wir machen ist die welt der
einzelne dinge zu begreifen und damit
und wir kommen damit zurecht indem wir
einzelne dinge unter universalen
beschreibungen begreifen aber was wir
nicht machen ist einfach rein
intellektuell denken oder oder er würde
vielleicht sagen das ist intellektuell
denken mindestens für menschen ist
universelle wahrheiten bei von einzelnen
zu gewinnen und dann bei aldingen
anzuwenden
okay gut das klingt plausibel und für
uns vor allem klingt das plausibel weil
das viel näher ist zu uns oder modernen
verständnis des denkens weil wir würden
wahrscheinlich auch sagen weil wir
neigen irgendwie alle importe dazu im
tourist ist das eigentliche denken wir
denken wahrscheinlich auch sie nicht
aber viele neigen dazu entweder zu
denken und wenn ja ok die wissen wir
überhaupt irgendwas weil wir einzelne
dinge in der welt der wahrnehmung
begegnen wir lernen davon dann können
wir das anwenden
wie auch immer aber diese sehr
hochkarätige vorstellung von hat es dort
lesen von den katholiken dass wir in
dieser welt der universalen zu schweben
das irgendwie nichts das was für uns als
wissen zählt normalerweise deswegen
werden wir alle bereit wären sie alle
bereit
zb zu sagen dass sie wissen dass ich vor
ihm stehe ohne dass sie ein sternchen
draufschreiben sagen ja das ist nicht
wirklich wissen weil wirkliches wissen
es wissenschaftern der wissenschaft ist
in einer universal zusagen sind nicht
und das würde pumpen hat sie auch nicht
sagen
für company ist wissen immer eine
auseinandersetzung mit der äußeren welt
das ist irgendwie sehr moderne internet
sogar im voraus eigentümer oder lockt
ein dessen sei ein schritt in die
richtung
also vielleicht sagen wir alle gut
gemacht kombination aber damals war das
gar nicht willkommen weil er jetzt die
unsterblichkeit der seele aus einer
anderen richtung infrage gestellt hat
hat es dadurch gemacht dass er das
unsterbliche an der mensch an dem mensch
universell und einheitlich gemacht hat
aber kompanie sagt jetzt alles was wir
machen also dass wir pro motiv machen
können machen wir durch den körper und
durch begegnung und anwendungen anderen
körpern und deswegen könnte man
eigentlich sagen dass die seele der die
das macht nur die wahrnehmung seele ist
wir haben nur die wahrnehmung säle und
durch die wahrnehmung szene begleichen
wir die welt und versteht sie will
verstehen sie und das heißt dass wir
nicht unsterblich sind
sorry und das sagt er wirklich sorry
weil er dann sagt ja das ist natürlich
nur die lehre die man erreichen würde
wenn man nur die mitteln der
naturphilosophie einsetzt nach
christentum ist natürlich ganz anders
und das behaupte ich nicht unbedingt um
wasser aber für das so verstehen ist
dass das ergebnis wir müssen damit leben
und das war natürlich sehr kontrovers
aus und uns aus zwei gründen gleich oder
aus dem offensichtlichen grund dass er
die unsterblichkeit der seele gefährdet
hat aber auch weil er diese gestoppt
sehr geschätzte analyse der menschlichen
zelle teilaspekt mensch aspekt das hat
er alle in frage gestellt für ihn gibt
es nur eine seele
und sie tut alles sie macht alles hat
verschiedene aktivitäten ist aber
eigentlich nur eine eine wahrnehmung
szene genau wie andere menschen genau
wie andere tiere
das ist ein anderes aspekt seiner lehre
das irgendwie modern vorkommt vielleicht
weil das ich glaube dass es was wir
wahrscheinlich auch denken oder in
heiden dazu denken wir sind nur tiere
die ein bisschen ford geschlossen als
die meisten anderen tiere und das ist
pompe nazis überzeugung als er
verabschiedet sich von dieser 44
vielteiligen oder dreiteiligen serie die
immer wieder vorgekommen ist
ich habe letzte woche woche gesagt
glaube ich dass man die beobachtung
machen kann das an das auffällige ideen
aus dass klassische installation schon
in der islamischen welt unabhängig
vorgekommen sind und das ist noch ein
beispiel war es ein philosoph es gab
mehrere philosophen aber vor allem ein
philosoph im surfen jahrhundert gab
namens gold barakat al-baradei die sein
name ist auf dem hände der mehr oder
weniger genau dasselbe sagen wollte er
wurde auch sagen vergiss es die die
seele hat keine teile
es gibt nur eine einheitliche stelle die
verschiedene kognitive fähigkeiten hat
und kann einerseits wahrnehmen
andererseits vorstellen andererseits
denken usw
es ist auffällig wie oft das passiert
dass die philosophen der islamischen
welt und in der la times klassischen
welt auf die taktiken kommen
aber nicht weil sie sich gegenseitig
beeinflusst haben sondern weil sie die
gleiche theorie angegriffen haben
okay das war pompe nazi jetzt niveau
augustine o niveau will dagegen
argumentieren und um das zu machen will
er eine sehr sehr starke unterscheidung
machen genau was sie nicht gemacht hat
er will eine sehr starke unterscheidung
machen zwischen menschen oder im
allgemeinen wesen die denken können und
wesen die nicht denken können nämlich
tiere und argumentiert sich deswegen
dafür dass sie das tier so unähnlich
sind dass sie eigentlich zu einer
anderen gattung gehören in einer hin es
ist irgendwie als hätten sie nie was er
sagen will dass er diese sehr strikte
unterscheidung zwischen denkende mensch
und nicht denken ein tier machen will
andererseits verabschiedet er sich von
der alten idee dass der mensch irgendwie
ein tier ist mein mann man könnte sagen
[Musik]
der mensch in der sozialstation war
immer der haben vernünftiges und
paparazzi betont tier und niveau betont
vernünftiges aber irgendwie kommen sie
beide zu dem ergebnis dass sie das
abschleppen vom platz sieben bleibt nur
ein fortgeschrittenes tier 2 niveau
bleibt ein vernunft wesen das was kein
tier mehr ist nicht dass er behaupten
würde dass tiergarten mit uns gar nichts
gemeinsam haben es sagt dass tiere die
reihe nach eingeordnet werden können
die sind je
die perfekte der sie sind perfekte je
nachdem wie ähnlich sie sind so menschen
zum beispiel tiere die nicht alle von
wahrnehmung szenen hat besitzen sind
weiter weg von menschen als volk als die
höhere mediale von farben oder tiere die
eine stärkere vorstellung seines denkens
vorstellungskraft haben sind perfekter
als diejenige die das nicht haben das
ist relativ typisch was an beim
einhalten heißt ist dass er sagen will
dass die dass wir als vernunft wesen
eine völlig andere gattung sind als die
nichtmenschliche tiere
interessanterweise sie erinnern sich an
die tücken von alberta größe
die kommen immer wieder vor in diesen
diskussionen und werden von bei niefern
nochmal erwähnt und dann sagt er ja also
wenn wenn ich diese unterscheidung
machen muss denn sind die prämien auf
unserer seite
weil sie sprechen können sie haben an
seine vernunft während er behauptet dass
aldi nichtmenschliche tiere wirklich nur
anscheinend der vernunft haben die
können nicht denken
auch wenn es so scheint dass sie das
machen können von daher genau wie ich
gesagt habe dass pomper nazi irgendwie
sehr modern wirkt die gegen die gegen
antwort von liefern wird sehr als
aristotelische sagen okay dann wollte
ich die platonische kommen aber hat kurz
hat jemand eine frage zu dieser debatte
okay so
die diese das was ich gerade gesagt habe
dass die das für das für ani wo die
menschen sehr strikt von den tieren
unterschieden werden
das ist was dass wir bei den flotten
kann eben nicht finden
wir finden die genau entgegengesetzte
behauptung dass es super wichtig ist
dass menschen ein tier aspekt haben
andererseits wollen sie nichts mit
pumpen sie gehen und sagen dass wir
wirklich nur sportliches mädchen zu
präsentieren sind sie wollen vielmehr
sagen dass wir das tierische und das
geistige in einer einheit kombinieren
und das ist das besondere an die
menschen an den menschen dass wir beide
seiten des universums kombinieren wir
sind das bindeglied des universums wie
fuji no sagt und hören dass ein bisschen
weiter zu erläutern
bei für kino der 1499 gestorben ist
finden wir eine wiederbelebung der alten
neue platonischen lehre wie gesagt das
kommt durch deswegen zustande dass man
durch humanismus lust hatte und
gelegenheit hatte und die fähigkeit
hatte viele texte aus der antike noch
mal zu lesen die eigentlich lange zeit
verloren
konsens unter anderem weil sie was ihr
wichtig ist ist irgendwas man nicht
vergessen soll ist dass texte aus byzanz
durch die später durch das späte
mittelalter kommen und dann nach dem
zerfall von konstantinopel durch die
osmanen wirklich nur in italien
zugänglich sind
also diese kommunisten haben eigentlich
all die griechische texte die wir haben
wir haben diese texte wahl die
humanisten sie hatten also die
handschriften die womit wir architekten
heutzutage lesen können sind alle zu
westeuropa gekommen weil sie in bislang
sechs ist haben und würden vorwiegend
durch die ausbeutung von konstantinopel
durch die westliche lateiner deswegen
existieren sie noch in frankreich und
hier in münchen und in der die
kommunisten dann waren begeisterte
schüler der griechischen sprache auch
der lateinischen sprache natürlich und
für kino war ein sehr gutes beispiel
dafür
er hatte er hat eine hand schafft für
alle dialoge platons die er als geschenk
bekommen hat von den medien von der
medici familie von cosimo de medici und
würde den auftrag gegeben die
platonische dialog ist die lateinische
sprache zu übersetzen und das hat er
gemacht
das sage ich nochmal sie wissen alle wie
viele platten es gibt ja er hat ihn
alleingang alle platonische dialoge in
die lateinische sprache übersetzt sehr
beeindruckend auch wenn er auch und
ältere übersetzungen manchmal benutzt
hat das ist ein atemberaubendes berg was
er gemacht hat und dann hat er noch dazu
die die dialoge kommentiert und hat
platin übersetzt und andere werke aus
der spätantike es ist wirklich
beachtlich was er gemacht hat man muss
natürlich sagen dass es damals keine
fernsehen gab
dass er hatte mehr zeit als wir es hier
haben also wenn er game of thrones schon
können hätte hat er vielleicht nur die
hälfte geschafft
auf jeden fall der hat nicht nur das
alles gemacht all diese übersetzungen
und kommentare geschafft sondern auch
ein langes werk das heißt katholische
theologie die nicht zufällig den titel
eines langen werks von des pokers teilt
aber der titel ist ein bisschen ab jeder
kennt es geht wirklich über die
unsterblichkeit der seele
und da bringt der hunderte argumente
dafür dass die zelle unsterblich sein
argumentiert auch gegen davos muss und
diese einheits lehre reinheit des
intellekts meine ich und um passau gibt
uns zu verstehen wie er die ganze welt
sieht und er versteht das sehr
platonisch bzw
nach dem muster platin oder dass der
assistent platins also er hat ganz oben
natürlich als erste ursache
und dann hat er indirekt wobei für ihn
ist das gleich engel oder die engeln
aber oft sagt er einfach engel singular
und dann gibt es die szene und dann
körper magnet an qualität und dein
körper und das sind 44 cent zählen bis
sind keine körper wir sind zählen
und es war für ihn sehr schön zu sehen
weil er diese diese stufe hier
eingeschoben wird qualität ist keine
kleine stufe in den klassischen neu
platonischen system aber das hat
vielleicht ein
das hat er da eingeführt einerseits war
her quellen in der antiken literatur
gefunden hat und andererseits war er
dann sagen konnte dass das die mitte des
systems ist also wir sitzen in der mitte
dieses systems und binden alles zusammen
deswegen sind wir das bindeglied dass
sie die seele ist das bindeglied des
universums und diese idee hat dann
seinen freund und jüngeren kollegen pico
della meran dollar beeinflusst hier
kommen wir kurz zu einem sehr berühmten
berg das heißt der natur - also über die
natur des menschen und ist eine war
eigentlich eine rede die er in rom geben
wollte als er eine liste von thesen
verteidigen wollte ecowas er ein sehr
reicher junger mann und hat angeboten
dass alles klassiker in italien
kostenlos nach rom reisen dürfte mit ihm
seine thesen zu debattieren
und dann hat der papst die thesen
gelesen und gesagt das wird nicht
stattfinden weil diese thesen zum teil
hektischen ein mystiker sich verteidigen
und erfolgreich müsste nach frankreich
frankreich fliehen kamen nach einer
weile zurück nach florenz ist dann aber
früh gestorben deswegen ist er sogar
früher als für gino dal gestorben obwohl
er vier junge war auf jeden fall die
eine idee die er in dieser
eröffnungsrede dann stark machen will
ist eben dass wir weil wir in der mitte
dieses systems existieren wir sind
teilweise engel und teilweise tier oder
sogar vielleicht teilweise göttlich und
teilweise tierisch und das ist irgendwie
eine alte idee die uns aus der früheren
geschichte etwas wie bekannt ist diese
idee dass der mensch einen sogenannten
sogenannte mikrokosmos ist
wir kombinieren und in uns die ganze
welt
alle aspekte der welt werden es sind in
den mensch vorhanden aber was bei pico
mindestens nach manchen auslegungen sehr
auffällig ist es die behauptung dass der
mensch sich wirklich entscheiden kann
welches als mit welchem aspekt er sich
identifizieren will so man kann engel
werden oder gott ähnlich werden oder
tierisch werden und es liegt wirklich in
unserer macht zu entscheiden was wir
sind oder werden was jeder von uns sein
will und es wird oft behauptet das ist
irgendwie ein anfang des typischen flur
modernen individualismus also diese
diese idee dass einer reinen
subjektivität oder freier wille wodurch
man die bedeutung des lebens selber
festlegen und bestimmen kann durch eine
grundlegende existenzielle entscheidung
ob man das wirklich so in pico alles
einlesen kann oder nicht ist umstritten
man sieht oft die den anfang dieser
modernen tendenz in pico in dieser rede
sie sehen übrigens wie oft das vorkommt
in der renaissance dass das was wir als
typisch für die firma frühe moderne
einschätzen schon im vom center oder
sechsten jahrhundert vor
genau wie vieles was in dem mittelalter
angeblich zu ersten mal aufgetaucht hat
vorher in der islamischen welt gegeben
hat ist oft so in der geschichte flüsse
wie das alles früher hofft dass man
meint wenn man richtig schaut das aber
für pico ist das wirklich haben nur ein
das ist wirklich nur eine folge von
dieser hat frische idee dass wir eine
skala oder also ein fast ein leiter der
existenz haben wo menschen genau in der
mitte sind und jede sind natürlich sehr
eindeutig unter uns angeordnet er sagt
sogar dass die ist dass es verschiedene
stufen wurde etappen der das tier wesen
es gibt noch mal ein bisschen wie niveau
je nachdem wie ähnlich sie sind so
menschen zum beispiel sind reptilien
fast sind ganz niedrig für ihn weil sind
was dagegen oder tallinn hat aber er
scheint zu denken dass reptilien sehr
schwache vorstellungskraft haben
deswegen sind sie weniger perfekt als
andere tiere werden
touristische tiere zum beispiel kühe
oder und hunde sind sehr perfekt weil
sie lernen können in dem menschlichen
leben zusammen zu machen das ist
natürlich sehr an der hand robust sein
tisch das tier ist fortgeschrittene
desto mehr das tier und der tele folgt
also er würde wahrscheinlich sagen
katzen sind bei weitem nicht so
fortgeschritten wie hunde weil meine
katze dass sie ja egal was ich will
aber das ist das ist natürlich irgendwie
zu erwarten aber es ist mindestens der
fall dass er eine eine skala von
vollkommenheit auch unter tieren
anerkennt aber menschen sind sehr fest
haben einen sehr festen platz über tiere
solange sie die richtige entscheidungen
treffen also solange sie sich nicht mit
dem tierischen aspekt
identifizieren und um das ein bisschen
zu erläutern wollte ich ein thema
auswählen was bei kino- und pico
vorkommt und auch bei mehreren anderen
ressorts alphorn und das ist die liebe
hier haben wir noch mal damit zu tun
dass renaissance komponisten mit hexen
sich mit tasten texten
auseinandersetzung setzten die sehr
lange außer acht gefallen sind oder gar
nicht gelesen wollen sind und ein
beispiel dafür ist die iss die das
symposium von platon beziehungsweise all
die sogenannte erotische theologen
würden im mittelland platon war würde
sowieso nicht gelesen im mittelalter das
auf den team aus seinen dialog über
kosmologie sie hatten ein werk wie das
symposium gar nichts aber als sie diese
handschriften aus besatz bekommen haben
haben sie sämtliche platonische dialoge
lesen können und dann sind sie auf
dieses dieses dialoge kommen das
symposium und das haben sie mal wer hat
hier das symposium gelesen als neugier
teil ob wäre das okay dann vielleicht
kurz stellten was das ist dass ein
dialog also symposien heißt heißt dass
man zusammen trinkt symposium zusammen
trinken und das ist ein dass es ein
treffen von wohlhabenden männern unter
anderem unter anderem sokratis die die
reihe nach reden halten wo sie liebe
kritisch
sie wollen dann reden halten wo sie ja
wo sie die liebe loben das ist lauter
lobgesänge zu diesem gott heraus oder so
das phänomen der liebe eine rede ist
berühmt das ist die rede von rohstoffen
ist der komische der comic dichter und
er erzählt diese diese berühmte
geschichte wo menschen ursprünglich
diese ball vorne gewesen waren mit
mitgliedern und sie würden zu kraftvoll
und würden von salz mit donner und blitz
halbiert und jeder davon ist es deswegen
ein halber mensch eigentlich oder da
könnte man sagen dass ein mensch ein
halbes gesamt wesen ist und unser
verlangen nach sex ist lust die andere
hälfte zu finden
also nochmal zu kombinieren und und das
ursprüngliche wesen zusammenzukriegen
das ist eine rede dann gibt es en
kreatives rede wo er beschreibt wie eine
weibliche philosophen der thema ihm
beigebracht hat was die liebe eigentlich
ist nämlich lust nach schönheit weil wir
irgendwie alle waage anerkennen dass die
schönheit in dieser welt ein abbild es
von der von der schönheit an sich die
form des schönen und wir sollen uns weg
von diesen weg von dieser örtlichen
schönheit drehen richtung vorne der
schönheit
das ist das symposium für gino steigt an
keinen kommentar dazu wenn man das
kommentare kommentar bezeichnen kann
dass das heißt der neue über die liebe
ist irgendwie ein kommentar über den das
symposium präsentiert sich aber als ein
weiteres dialog wo mehrere humanisten
sie sich sammeln und reden halten wo
jede rede
eine auslegung ist eine rede in den
symposien und angeblich war das ein
echtes ereignis wahrscheinlich
literarisch sehr ausgedehnt und kreativ
dargestellt aber die eigentliche idee
ist dass wir
mehrere sprecher haben und jeder
sprecher kommentiert eine rede aus dem
er gerne
dialog ist sehr interessant wir das
gemacht hat und dann schreit pico ein
traktat über die liebe wo er für kinos
die den angreift obwohl sie gut
befreundet waren
er war jungens ziemlich arrogant und
dann und nachdem und vielleicht weil wir
diese interessante texte haben haben wir
dann eine ganze reihe von texten wo
andere alten auch oft jetzt in
volkssprache also italienisch nicht im
lateinischen pico und china wo ist sie
die liebe handeln oft in form eines
dialogs zb pietro bembo macht das ein
jüdischer denker leonie brill macht das
thalia tarragona eine kreuzes an die die
als figur in einem anderen dialog eines
einen des anderen des schriftstellers
auftaucht und wir da dargestellt als
verteidigerin der körperlichen liebe und
vielleicht um das zu beantworten
schreibt sie ein dialog wo die liebe
sehr geistlich und rein vorgestellt wird
und das ist sehr nach dem muster von
fujinon so was für china über die liebe
sagen will ist dass echte liebe gar
nichts mit körperlichen lust zu tun hat
und dass sie viel mehr ein verlangen
erst nach der echten schönheit wie
platons sagt oder wieso hat es in seiner
rede im symposium sagt und das heißt
eigentlich die schönheit des intellekts
wissen engels wurde die schönheit gottes
und er hat eine ganze theorie der
schönheits die schönheit ist nach dem
kino was er sagt es ist das blühen des
guten
alles was gut ist zeigt sich als schön
und das was gut ist für uns ist
natürlich nicht das was unter uns lassen
und uns befindet körper und die
qualitäten des körpers also die die
schönheit eines körpers ist für uns
nicht gut ist eine ablenkung die dass
die gute schönheit für uns ist die
schönheit der seele selbst zum beispiel
die tuben oder die schönheit die uns des
guten das gute bei den höheren
prinzipien seitz jetzt fragen sie sich
weiterhin noch mal was das mit tieren zu
tun hat arbeitet er ist werden jetzt
hier sehr stark thematisiert weil das
heißt dass sexuelles verlangen bei kino
das nichts menschliches ist das ist das
tierische tiere haben ein hamm lust auf
körperliche betätigung das haben wir
auch aber das hat gar nichts mit mir zu
tun
nach china also es gibt das ist eine
kunst hässliche verwechslung zwischen
lust und liebe
und jetzt sagt sogar ausdrücklich dass
die dass das tierische verhalten wo man
die schönheit als körperliche schönheit
definiert und sie als anreiz für
körperlichen könnte also er sagt sogar
dass liebe gar nichts mit tasten zu tun
hat sobald man sobald das sinne an
involviert ist sind wir sind da
außerhalb des bereichs der leber und das
ist ein sehr gutes beispiel wie die
platonische von minister platonisch
zwischen tier und mensch verschieden
unterscheiden in diesem fall hat das gar
nichts mit denken zu tun oder nicht
mitdenken in der ersten linie zu tun
hier hat es mit liebe und lust zu tun
also lust es wird ihre liebe ist für
menschen und das ist ein punkt wo pico
für gino kritisiert weil er sagt liebe
es nicht unbedingt das streben nach
blute des guten
das ist das leben nach das was man als
gut nimmt also dass anscheinend gute
natürlich kann man recht haben und man
kann nach zum beispiel gott streben oder
die tugend und dann steht man nach einem
ersten guten man kann aber auch liebe
für einen ein gutes haben was nur ein
schein gut ist und deswegen sagt er
das liebe gemeinsam zwischen menschen
und tiere vorhanden ist
tiere haben auch liebe weil das was für
das was sie also gut empfinden ist die
körper sind die körper anderen tieren
sie empfinden das als gut deswegen zählt
das alles liebe für tiere
das finde ich wirklich interessanten
immer noch mal die tiere für dass wir es
nicht der zentrale punkt natürlich in
diesen plakaten
trotzdem finde ich sehr interessant zu
sehen wie das vieh dass die
etymologische debatte spiegelt die wir
gerade bei den pendants jährigen gesehen
haben
wir haben die idee denken und vernunft
bei tieren und menschen auf beiden
seiten auf oder denken und vernunft ist
nur das menschliche wurden hier haben
wir genau das video gegeben aber mit
liebe liebe es nur das menschliche das
kino und auch donna jede these oder
prothese liebe es allgemein kommt
überall in der in der tierwelt vor
wir sind nur die tiere die die bessere
güter begreifen können
das finde ich spannend was die diese
autoren auch diskutieren ist was im
mittelalter oft gefehlt hat war die
frage die auch zb indien gesehen haben
ob es zulässig ist tiere zu essen und
das scheint ein ganz anderes thema zu
sein ist aber nichts weil das durchaus
mit fatalismus zu tun haben
jetzt kommen wir zurück zu ferien genau
wie das symposion wird profis ist die
abstinenz ja also gegen fleischkonsum
wird oder enthaltsamkeit das führen von
fleischkonsum dass wir jetzt
wiederentdeckt und übersetzt von china
das ist noch ein paar tonnen
platonischen text den er übersetzt hat
und das hat er sehr gerne gerne gefunden
und wollte sehr betonen wie wichtig das
ist weil manche andere autoren platon
und platin ismus angegriffen haben weil
es so ausdrücklich heimisch ist und was
nicht so sehr platon vielleicht aber
neue platz muss ist hat auffällig sehr
viel heimische leere treten zum beispiel
aussagen über die heidnische götter also
sehr panisch
diese neue personalsituation und serien
haben manche gesagt hey wieso liest er
dass das alles gegen das ist alles gegen
christentum
ein beispiel ist das die neue theorien
haben wieso man tiere an die götter
opfern sollen
und das stimmt das kommt bei zum
beispiel ihren blick vor und deswegen
war war überglücklich als er diesen text
gefunden hat wo ein platonischer
ausdrücklich sie sich aus als wirklich
gegend hier verwendet wobei profis noch
mal sagt dass ein guter platonischer gar
nichts mit ihr opfer und fleischkonsum
zu tun haben werden wenn wir an die
götter offen dann sollen wir unsere
ideen oder gedanken opfern wie sie ja
wie wir damals gesehen haben
und das und das wollen deswegen eine ein
beispiel für kino- oder vielleicht sogar
ein haupt beleg für die idee dass
platonische heimischen flüsse wie doch
mit präsent um vereinbar ist
und das war nicht das war nichts an der
das einzige mal in der renaissance wo
dieser text wichtig geworden ist weil es
aus einer ganz anderen richtung zustande
gekommen ist dass eine debatte
entstanden ist ob man fleisch essen soll
oder nicht
und innerhalb dieser debatte zitieren
die die fleischkonsum gegner oft
porfirio diese debatte kommt nicht aus
platonische philosophie sondern aus der
medizin
hier kommen wir so kadaver und diese
zitat die was also viele mediziner haben
die alte frage besprochen die schon
ausführlich von zum beispiel galerien
geschaffen wird was sollen wir hessen um
gesund zu sein
und da haben sie in galerien lesen
können dass man das das beste die beste
nahrung für jedes tier ist die nahrung
wo die nahrung die einen körper hat der
haben ähnliches zu den körper der
ernährt werden soll
okay was ist das nach gallien ist das
schweinefleisch schweinefleisch ist so
ähnlich zu menschenfleisch wie es geht
unter fleischarten und deswegen ist dass
die gesündeste art fleisch
okay gut und dann haben sie das überlegt
und gesehen dass das ist eigentlich das
impliziert dass wenn wir nur fleisch
essen würden wären wir sehr gesund ist
das richtig oder nicht
und dann gab es zwei meinungen dazu
einerseits jahr fleisch isst gesund also
soll es vielleicht nicht nur fleisch
essen aber sehr viel da wirst du stark
da wirst du kräftig andererseits gibt es
die meinung dass fleisch ungesund ist
und dass man leichtes essen soll die
profis sagt profil sagt natürlich sogar
dass man den körper schwach halten will
damit dass die zelle mit ablenkt und
dieses diese idee diese du bist was du
isst idee ist sehr stark in der ganzen
hessens debatte in der renaissance
übrigens es gibt einen ein buch was an
bald in erscheinung aber die autorin hat
mir freundlicherweise eine kopie
geschickt damit diese vorlesung
vorbereiten konnte von chili moderator
das ein ganzes buch über die wirkung von
profis der abstinenz in der renaissance
und all diese debatten was man essen
sollen was man nicht essen sollen und es
ist wirklich interessant zu sehen wie
diese diese idee diese du bist was du
hörst idee auf beiden seiten erwähnt
werden kann weil natürlich will man
nichts schweinisch werden
also wenn du es wenn du wirklich
nachdenkt ist unser event wenn ich ein
wenig schweine es dann werde ich wie ein
schwein also einerseits soll ich das ist
so ähnlich wie das ist ähnlich zu mir
würde vielleicht will ich nicht ähnlich
wie ein schwein sein
ja und deswegen ist dieses zitat das ist
da los es ist aus einer einem
zusammenhang an wo er diät bespritzt und
hier sagt er
die deutsche essen vorwiegend die milch
der bestien vor allem
und deswegen sind sie bestialisch die
sind ihrer kundin speedway hat wie
aggressiv sie sind die beiden leicht
geärgert sind irgendwie sowas wie
furchtlos vielleicht oder armut und sind
aber ziemlich rustikal
so ist ein deutscher nach adana aber
gibt der philosophische punkt ist die
deutsche sind so weiß sie das essen das
essen beeinflusst ihre ihre moralische
neigungen und an das ist allgemein der
fall dass das sagen die sagen viele
es gibt sogar einen berg und jetzt werde
ich doch etwas zu heraus muss sagen
erlassen das hat einen dialog
geschrieben
das glaubt man fast nicht sein dialog
zwischen einem fischhändler und einem
metzger wurde der metzger philosophische
argumente dafür bringt das man fleisch
essen soll und der fischhändler sagt
nein man soll nur gemüse und fisch essen
weil es gesund ist und leiter und dann
der last den metzger sagen dass er
jemanden kannte der krank geworden ist
und sich näher nur erholen konnte
dadurch dass er fleisch gegessen hat und
das ist natürlich ein bericht über
erasmus selbst weil wir kennen aus
anderen quellen dass er auch anscheinend
fast gestorben ist und dann hat er diät
gewechselt mehr fleisch gegessen und hat
sich erholen können
also diese diese spannung fleisch
fleisch macht dich tierisch oder fleisch
ist gut und gesund das läuft durch die
kanzlerin und hat eine interessante an
ein interessantes al qaidas aspekt
nachdem sie sich so genannte neue welt
entdecken und die also die die leute die
immer noch auf deutsch indianer heißen
aber in meinem land jetzt die native
american das heißt also die
einheimische amerikaner werden von
columbus und so weiter entdeckt und dass
das imports natürlich die europäer aus
mehreren gründen wieso hat gott erlaubt
dass diese tausende millionen von leuten
dort wohnen ohne was von jesus christus
zu hören und das für eine hat 1000 jahre
wuchs oft kommen sie in die also werk
können sie gerettet werden wie es also
ein theologisches problem müssen sofort
rüber fahren und sie alle
kristallisieren bevor es zu spät ist ok
er ist das aber auch wie leben diese
leute angeblich hatten sie sehr langes
leben
sie hatten irgendwie das geheimnis
gefunden in der natur gut zu leben wird
auch gesagt dass sie der natur nachlesen
leben oder in einer natürlichen weise
leben bewegen wie beeindruckend was sie
machen
und übrigens die sind kannibalen
vielleicht deswegen leben sie so lang
die essen genau das richtige fleisch
wenn mein denken wir nach und welches
fleisch ist an ähnlichsten zu den
menschlichen körper menschliches fleisch
andererseits würde das auch als
begründung hervor gehoben warum menschen
entschuldigen warum kannibalen gar keine
menschen sind die sind nur tiere weil
menschen würden so etwas nicht machen
und vielleicht ist das auch gott sei
dank deswegen ist es okay dass sie
nichts über christus wissen weil die
sind sowieso keine menschen das sind die
neue technik
also alles als sehr interessant und hat
sehr viel mit ihr zu tun also die diese
idee dass dass wir die welt in tier und
mensch sehr scharf aufsplitten können
dass das gerät unter druck wenn sie
diese leute entdecken weil sie der
meinung sind dass das menschen das sind
millionen von menschen die sich die
irgendwie tierisch leben und es ist
diese sind irgendwo an der grenze
zwischen mensch und tier und bekräftigt
wahrscheinlich die annahme dass leute
wie niveau nicht leicht hatten das ist
eine gewisse kontinuität zwischen tier
und mensch gibt also von insekten ganz
unten
reptilien dom esstische tiere dem
kannibalen und dann rustikal ex deutsche
und dann gut gebildete humanisten ganze
gruppen wobei als amerikaner weit unter
den deutschen fans war es für sie diese
idee dass man mit schaf unterscheiden
kann wo die vernunft oder bot die das
menschliche ansicht dann in dieses
system ein kommt dass es eine sehr
starke tendenz in der renaissancezeit
und vielleicht die stärkste fassung
davon konnte bei tommaso campanella vor
dass das ist nicht vollständig er stirbt
in denen alles 1630 also erst jetzt sind
wir schon im siebzehnten jahrhundert und
hat sich für all diese themen themen und
texte die wir jetzt besonnen haben hat
er sich interessiert zum beispiel war
ein atom ist und hat sich für medizin
interessiert hat profis bekannt war
kritik des atheismus kannte sich sehr
gut aus kurzum und und neigt dazu zu
denken das wie gesagt dass es eine
gewisse kontinuität zwischen tier und
mensch ist also erst auf der seite von
ballack
das tier doch irgendwie schon an
vernunft zahl haben und geht noch weiter
als wahrer und stimmt profi duos zu dass
tiere auch sprache verstehen und
verwenden können macht den punkt den
auch piräus markt gemacht hat dass wenn
tiere auch wenn tiere geräusche machen
die wir nicht verstehen das heißt nicht
dass das keine sprache ist weil es ist
nur eine sprache die wir nicht verstehen
und bringt eine super beispiel vor
meiner meinung nach er sagt ich habe
einen hund in neapel erlebt der den
besitzer aus polen waren und dieser hund
konnte polnisch verstehen aber näher
pathologischem elektronisches
italienischen nichts als er konnte eine
menschliche sprache verstehen aber eine
andere nichts was natürlich stimmt es
super beobachtung zeigt sehr wohl das
thema sprache sprache nicht beherrschen
vielleicht aber mindestens verstehen
also sehr gut und es gab einen guten
grund warum kann man ausgerechnet
campanella das sagen wollte nämlich dass
er an sich ist wahr was pantheismus
kurzum ist dass die theorie dass die
ganze welt beseelt ist und das haben wir
schon gesehen würden sie sich an platon
weltseele es gibt eine zelle die alles
ein trinkt aber das ist nicht was er
meint was er meint ist dass alle
natürliche dinge bewusstsein haben oder
er würde sagen wahrnehmung zum beispiel
pflanzen können wahrnehmen nicht nur
tiere deswegen können sie in richtung
sonne drehen oder nahrung suchen wasser
und nahrung in der karte finden
und er behauptet sogar dass zb steine
auch eine sehr niedrige niedrige stufe
von wahrnehmung haben
und damit scheinen wir bereit sein die
philosophische ideen zu erreichen die
wir haben also dass das wir dass die
grenze zwischen unseren tieren sehr
verschwommen ist dass die grenzen
zwischen tier und nicht hier sehr
verschwommen ist das alles zusammen eine
verschworene einheit oder kontinuität
von menschen ganz oben zu stehen ganz
unten aber keines keine scharfe linien
und deswegen ist überraschend dass das
nächste was wir erreichen dass einige
intel design wird die genau in die
andere richtung geht wird die theorie
von descartes der behaarten will das
tier nur maschinen sind automaten und um
das auszugleichen wären wir ein eine
zweite philosophin nächstes nächste
woche betrachten er in cornwall die
diese praxis muss sie dann weiter bringt
also werden nächste woche zwei
entgegengesetzte meinungen aus der
frühen moderne haben kann weil alles ist
besetzt alles ist hat ein psychiater in
celle teil oder der card nur die
menschen haben eine seele und die paar
tiere haben kein kein inneres leben kein
muslim mehr als ein stein haben würde
also das wird spannend sein hoffentlich
danke fürs kommen ein bisschen